[Music]
now I imagine you're here this week to
talk about what's going on in the cloud
but I hope while you're here you're
still considering making smart use of
the resources down here on earth
you know I'm personally a big fan of our
planet and I can't I can't believe I'm
actually gonna say this even though
there's a there's a NASA display about
fifty yards that way about finding the
next planet with life on it we need to
consider that we're probably gonna be
here for a little while so even though
our cloud is not white or fluffy and and
unpredictable moisture is usually a bad
thing it has real impact here on earth
the resources that we use so this
session today is all about focusing on a
commitment to the environment what does
it mean to prioritize sustainability as
we make decisions as IT practitioners as
we set goals for our organizations and
ultimately in the products that we
design and develop you're gonna hear
from three companies that care a lot
about the smart use of the earth's
resources my name's Chris Talbott I work
in Google cloud I work with customers
across the globe helping them understand
how a move to the cloud can help them
become more sustainable and I'll share
some of that experience and why Google
cloud is sustainable platform but I'm
honestly really excited about what my
friends are going to share about a
company that is literally an icon for
environmental stewardship and how do
they incorporate that into their
organization and then a solar company
who is you know effectively using cloud
technology to make renewable energy
accessible for all so let's get right
into it at Google similar to our mission
of making information universally
accessible and useful we also have a
mission to build sustainability into
everything that we do as a company
you know breaking down what does
sustainability built-in mean it means
from hardware to the offices that we
build to the data centers that we build
we're gonna prioritize sustainability in
that value chain that could mean
incorporating as much as 75 percent
post-consumer recycled plastics in our
hardware to focusing on buying ugly
produce in our cafes buying all the
funny-looking fruits and vegetables that
would otherwise not be purchased by you
know restaurants and food providers but
I'm gonna focus on the two areas that
are probably most impactful for you as a
as a cloud user or a potential cloud
user and that's data centers and
renewable energy and you know within
these two areas we've really taken that
sustainability mission to heart by
innovating and building more technology
back into our environmental practices to
effectively make them more sustainable
by pushing our innovation kind of
upstream
you as a user downstream get a better
experience so I'll take a second to
highlight some of those areas that you
know essentially the stuff that you can
only get from from Google cloud first
data centers are at the heart of our
company and everything that we do it
powers Google cloud platform it powers
all the other Google products that
billions of users throughout the world
use and you know this is really the
critical part of the sustainability
story for you as a user because all of
us are increasingly going digital and
digital transformation isn't about just
using new technology stuff it's honestly
about betting your business on a digital
future and ultimately you're going to
use more technology stuff which means
more data center use and more energy and
with two percent or more of the world's
electricity already going to data
centers this is only going to grow but
it's actually one area where innovation
can have an incredible impact compared
to five years ago we actually deliver
seven times the compute per watt of
energy that we use in our data centers
Google clouds actually the best at using
getting the most out of the energy that
we draw the way that you measure this is
something called power usage
effectiveness or PUA it's calculated by
taking you know the total energy that
you use in your data center and dividing
that by only the stuff that you use to
actually provide computing power for
every kind of watt of energy that you
use how much are you gonna have to use
for all the other stuff like facilities
and cooling and all the things that make
a datacenter work for us we only need 11
percent extra stuff to do that so it
comes down to an average PUA across our
fleet of 1.1 one and you know you as a
user of Google cloud products and
services you get to take advantage of
that as 50% better than the average data
center out there and that's efficiency
that we deliver to you and using our
services and you know unique to Google
one of the ways we're able to achieve
that efficiency is we actually use our
own machine learning technologies in our
data centers you know when it comes to
controlling a data center it's actually
a really you know complicated and unique
beast there's millions of components
that are relatively fickle to
unpredictable changes in the environment
so when you're managing a data center
trying to manage these components in a
very manual way is is really inefficient
and kind of out of the box you know
manufacturing or control systems
industrial control systems they aren't
universally applicable across the data
center so when you're facing a challenge
of trying to get better at predicting
unpredictable things from millions of
inputs neural networks can do a really
good job at doing that that's what
they're designed to do essentially learn
from millions of inputs and get better
about predicting the future so our our
machine learning actually controls the
cooling which is the major part of the
energy draw within a data center across
our fleet
you know I mentioned the other area
being renewable energy and energy in
general that's critical to you as a user
of Google Cloud you know running our
business across Google requires us to
use a lot of electric
city and you know combating climate
change requires all of us to transition
to a you know clean energy future so at
Google we match every unit of
electricity that we use across our
company with a unit of renewable energy
that we've purchased somewhere from a
zero carbon source in pursuing this goal
to reach a hundred percent match of our
energy we became the largest corporate
purchaser of renewable energy in history
and some of that investment in renewable
energy actually goes to wind power and
similar to our data centers we found
ways to make unique use of the Google
technology to help make wind power more
valuable so the thing with renewable
energy is it has to make financial sense
to that hundred percent match that I
just showed you it represents over five
billion dollars in investment from
Google and in order to make financial
sense the energy that we use it has to
be more predictable to be more valuable
to the grid energy that you can't
predict is actually less valuable that
energy that you can get consistently
contributing to the grid so we applied
the m/l to our wind farms to predict how
they're going to produce energy 36 hours
in advance and this machine learning
algorithm was essentially trained on
weather forecasts and by integrating
this into our wind farms we're actually
able to increase the value of the wind
energy that we were producing by 20% so
with Google working to make renewable
energy a viable and cost-effective
source for our operations you as a user
get that benefit the benefit essentially
of being carbon neutral so any
organization that moves infrastructure
or applications to Google cloud platform
you reduce the net carbon emissions
associated with your usage to zero
everything that runs in our cloud is net
carbon free I know I just said the same
thing three times but I want to get this
point across it's critically important
if your organization's
any sort of emissions or sustainability
goals you know this is the part that
enables you as a developer or an IT
infrastructure person to participate in
that goal setting and to actually be a
champion for sustainability and a
champion for change within your
organization you know ultimately we at
Google invest in sustainability to
empower all of you organizations
governments nonprofits individuals to
use the technology in our cloud and our
other applications to create a more
sustainable world you know one part is
the platform Google cloud platform
available to you to build on and we
actually we really believe that you know
in addition to you know price and high
performance and reliability of our
systems
you should get sustainability built into
the platform that you use one of the
other ways you know we're really focused
on empowering you as customers is
through data we all know information can
make that can help us make better
decisions about our future so lots of
the other teams throughout Google the
Geo team in particular works with
research and environmental organizations
to get the information that we have into
the hands of scientists and policy
makers that can make a difference Earth
engine the example here has enabled you
know a hundred thousand plus scientists
throughout the the globe to get a deeper
understanding of our planet so there are
opportunities available like this to you
too as a cloud user bigquery in
particular has lots of publicly
available geographic data sets that you
can use and help make better decisions
about our future
but honestly the rest is is up to you to
take this platform to take the data to
take the partnership that we have and
and build for the future and I honestly
hope you do because we've all seen
through you know the beautiful very high
definition lens of our next presenter
what's at stake for our planet so
without further ado I'd like to invite
Melissa Wiley from National Geographic
partners up to the stage thank you
Thanks great so thank you Chris and
thank you to Google for having me here
today so I thought before I jumped into
this I'd offer you guys a little bit of
inspiration to get started I think
that's what we do best at National
Geographic is we inspire people don't
worry I'm a professional photography has
the power to good photography has the
power power power the power to undo your
assumptions about the world change your
perspective on life and surprise people
with something that they had no idea
existed inspired horrify stop time for a
moment there's an incredible passport to
people's lives images are so powerful
that they can change the course of
people's lives they can change the
course of history photography can change
the world never underestimate the power
is still frame how can we make the
horror that we see in these pictures
stop when people see this photograph I
hope that they are overcome
with a sense of urgency I want them to
ask and scream for change to see that oh
that could be me and make connections
between people it's a universal language
one little hammer a weapon against
what's wrong out there you have to care
you really have to care it sounds simple
Brett I even get emotional sometimes
when I talk about you cannot do superior
work if you're indifferent how are you
gonna do that it's not the individual
photograph it's what you did with it and
who you engage with it that makes it
powerful well we live in a world where
it's easy to say that people don't care
anymore has been proven to me time and
again that people do care how could you
ever be done no you don't ever think you
know you just have to do it there's
always one more picture just two things
it takes like years of working just wait
a minute one more just to hone your
vision that'll be done no it won't if
you want to be a photographer a
particularly a photojournalist you want
to learn about the world and you want to
learn about yourself and you want to
find things that you genuinely care
about because that would be the source
of the greatest work you'll do
[Music]
great so I hope everybody enjoyed that
my name is Melissa Wiley and I am vice
president of digital products at
National Geographic and I'm sure as you
can probably all guess after watching
that video I've got just about the best
job in the world I get to work with
photographers scientists and explorers
who just like all of you who have
gathered here care deeply about the
planet and today I just want to offer
you a brief glimpse into how we take our
own public message about creating a
public of sorry a planet in balance and
we also look at ourselves in words to
see how we can incorporate that message
into our own corporate responsibility
so the spirit of exploration has always
really been at the heart and soul of
everything we do at National Geographic
before there was Pinterest Instagram
Facebook National Geographic was really
how we connected the world to people
cultures and critical changes in the
planet but now more than ever we
understand the importance of using
photography and storytelling to inspire
people to take action for us it all
starts with a sense of purpose
National Geographic believes that when
people understand about the world around
them they care deeply about it and they
want to take responsibility for it on
top of our television and our magazine
National Geographic reaches
approximately half a billion people
across our social channels and with that
scale comes the opportunities to really
bring communities together to drive
change and that's why weeds how the
stories of our photographers and our
scientists and our explorers who are
documenting our world and in order to
inspire everybody here to go out and
make change but not only does National
Geographic have a long history of being
a leader at inspiring all of you we've
long been a leader looking inward at
ourselves to understand what actions we
can take towards sustainable business
practices so we've adopted a corporate
responsibility policy that we share with
pretty much everyone we work with we
share this with employees we share it
with vendors partners and all of our
suppliers so we want to work towards
carbon neutrality we're working towards
a zero landfill waste we want to
practice wise resource stewardship and
most importantly we really want to have
a healthy and engaged workforce
not geo we're committed to operating our
estate our facilities as sustainably as
possible our headquarters in Washington
DC first became LEED certified in 2003
through our efforts of tracking energy
maintenance waste and office supplies we
were able to increase that from silver
to gold in 2009 and we actually achieved
our sixth certification just last year
in 2018 in addition to this great work
National Geographic also now receives
50% of our energy from solar a few other
accomplishments that we achieved in just
2018 we earned Energy Star
certifications for our headquarters
we've also been going through a process
to renovate our buildings as part of
that renovation we're now putting a
kitchen on every floor that offers
things like reusable dishware low
landfill coffee bottle bottleless water
fountains as part of our renovations
we've been recycling tons of office
furniture art supplies as well as
electronics and metal from the
renovations and with that money that we
save as well as the proceeds from our
products we're then able to reinvest
back into our nonprofit arm who has
awarded over 14,000 grants so that more
curious people can go out into the world
and inspire all of you to take action
our goal is to identify cultivate and
develop the change makers of today and
tomorrow one example of this is our
planet or plastic initiative that we
launched in May of 2018 this is a
multi-year effort about raising
awareness around the global plastic
crisis in order to help reduce the
amount of similar use plastics that's
making it into the world's oceans
as part of this initiative not only as
National Geographic asking all of you to
go out and take a look at your own usage
of single-use plastic and pledge to
reduce that use we're also taking a look
inward and we have initiated a plastic
audits across our entire organization so
that we can understand the extent of our
use across our supply chain as well as
work towards eliminating it so at
National Geographic we also understand
the power of technology to create
connections and drive empathy and most
importantly increase our awareness and
understanding of one another so this is
one of my favorite videos what you're
taking a look at here is an example of
our VR theater that we launched in
October of last year
so we now have an oculus Go headset that
is hooked up to all 400 seats in the
room so that everybody can have the same
360 experience at the same time it's
really fun so however we realized that
not only do we have the opportunity and
responsibility to connect our consumer
towards environmental issues but we
realize that we need to take a look at
our internal infrastructure as well so
the National Geographic image collection
the National Geographic image question
is the record of truth for all
photography assets at National
Geographic this database not only holds
the photographs themselves but it holds
information about contracts rights and
actually the physical location so if you
want to go down and actually find that
original Afghan girl print you're going
to take a look in the image collection
and that's going to tell you where to go
and actually pull that print off the
shelves last year we found ourselves in
a situation where that system had to be
taken offline
and while that was extremely and
extremely is an understatement it was
extremely inconvenient for everyone who
uses the system it gave us an
opportunity to take a step back and
really take a look at that 20 year old
system and make some critical decisions
about how we wanted to move forward with
it as a result we decided to partner
with Google we know that Google shares
similar passions as National Geographic
around sustainability the actions that
took this system offline unfortunately
really didn't earn us a lot of good will
with our photographers and we knew that
the steps that we took to bring the
system back online and we really wanted
to be able to say that we were storing
their photographs as sustainably as
possible we wanted to be able to prove
to our photographers that we recognized
the importance of their collections and
that we share common values with them so
we partnered with Google and we moved
this system to the cloud and just over
two months so this was an exciting
process for us and it's really been a
huge success story for us to bring this
back online we're now in the process of
partnering with Google to really try and
understand those energy savings that we
took when we migrated this system from
our on-premise facility into the cloud
so we've been able to provide Google
with a bunch of statistics about our
legacy system and then Google is helping
us to calculate that to really
understand what savings that we've
earned so this study is still ongoing
we're still we're just starting to get
in some early learnings but some of the
things that we are seeing is that we are
going to incur greenhouse emission
savings over the course of the year that
equal of around heating an average sized
home for about 30 to 40 months or
driving a car for about 25,000 miles and
those those thefts are exciting to us
they are relatively small but the image
collection it is also a very small
portion of our overall infrastructure
and we feel like this is going to make a
great case study for us to then go to
our executives and say that we think
sustainability needs to be part of our
benchmarks in all of our infrastructure
it's gonna help get us towards that
carbon-neutral goal that we talked about
earlier so that's just a brief look
gonna now hand this over to Jake who
have talked to you a lot about the work
National Geographic has done to look at
our own Corporation and Jake's going to
come up here and talk about products
that you all can use to take a look at
your own footprint hi everyone I'm Jake
walkman I run software product and
engineering for SunPower
and if you're not familiar with Sun
power maybe if you are you may know that
we make the world's most efficient solar
cells and panels and we offer those all
around the world to customers everywhere
as well as in the US where we package
them as solutions for residential and
commercial customers and so it's my
team's job to make our software at Sun
power as amazing as our hardware we're
here today to talk about a new
technology we've built on top of Google
cloud that we think does that but first
let's talk hardware so this is the solar
Stratus plane that will soar to 80
thousand feet into the stratosphere
powered just on solar cells specifically
SunPower solar cells why because our
cells are up to 22.7% efficient and
that's exactly the kind of power output
you need when you have a limited
wingspan with which to power a plane
this plane and this team prove that
Solar is here it's ready now it's ready
for the most difficult applications you
can throw at it and it's powerful it's
also powerful enough for Google or
rather Google and alphabets spin-out
project loon project loon if you're not
aware sends balloons aloft for months on
end to provide Internet service to
remote parts of the world and you can
see down here it's running on SunPower
solar panels in very low temperatures
all times of the day
and those are the very same cells that
go on homeowners roofs here in the US
and around the world you can see them up
there kind of looks like a skylight
we've made 10 gigawatts of solar power
since our first factory opened that's
equivalent to setting up two offsetting
40 million metric tons of carbon dioxide
or roughly taking 9 million cars off the
road for a year that's a lot of solar
but even as Soler's taken off we've only
reached about 3% of American homes we
have 97 percent to go and I think that
we have kind of two big problems that we
need to solve to get to that hundred
percent first I'd say we have an
awareness problem homeowners and
businesses don't realize the extent to
which solar can save them money can help
the environment and also decentralized
energy can provide a degree of energy
independence and secondly we have a
workflow problem getting that solar
panel on the roof and getting it design
to get aget installed is actually a very
difficult thing to solve and so we try
to solve both with software we want to
make solar as easy to buy and install as
any other consumer electronics so who
here remembers televisions raise your
hand yeah not quite a relic of the past
yet right but buying a TV is pretty
simple and pretty easy they come in some
pretty standard sizes right you got 65
inches 55 inches all the way down to 32
and so when you're going through the
process of buying a television as a
consumer you think I have a wall I have
a credenza I have a media center does
the TV fit can I see it from my couch
it's pretty simple right understanding
what size of television how much TV you
need well solar is not that simple every
house is different every roof unique
we're pointed in orientation toward the
Sun in different ways they're pipes and
chimneys you can't see here in this
simplified diagram and it becomes a very
complex
process it becomes a custom widget for
every homeowner
and so that's our challenge how do we
simplify that and I'll show you the
state-of-the-art I'll show you how we
actually quote today the quote is so
important to understanding the value
proposition to the homeowner and to
providing them an accurate estimate of
how much energy they'll save and how
much money we'll save and so here's how
we do it today we take a look at the
roof this this is actually deceptively
complex and we say okay there's a
chimney down there there five skylights
can't put solar there and I don't know
if you see this right there but those
are little pipes they're really hard to
see actually hard for our design team to
see and they're about nine of them at
least nine of them that I can see with
my naked eye but that's not all
there's also local jurisdictions and
either take those into account as you're
designing a solar power system as well
and so most most towns and cities and
counties require walkways along the
ridgeline and along the front in the
back of the house you can actually
access the roof at any time and so it
gets it gets even more complex their
trees and bushes all around the house
and those are shading the house so it's
kind of like hard to know where exactly
should I put those solar panels and how
tall are these trees because this isn't
just a two-dimensional problem this is a
three-dimensional problem this house
actually happens to be on a hill and the
trees some are higher some are lower
can't tell that from the overhead view
alone and so our designers spend 30
minutes per house thousands of times a
week to generate a solar design
I'll show you a sped-up video of how
that works here it is
they're outlining the roof this is the
current state of the art sped up 50x
this is what they do 2,000 times a week
to generate solar designs for our
customers making sure all the roof
planes are in the right spot putting in
those walkways getting the roof plane
just right putting in more walkways so
we're about five minutes in right now
getting the pipes and the skylights
so they're a hundred million future
solar homes the United States at our
current pace it would take us a century
to design them all who has time for that
I don't have time for that the planet
certainly doesn't have time for that so
there must be a better way and we are
here today to talk about it and announce
it we call it Sun power instant design
and it's built on Google cloud a
homeowner enters an address and within
60 seconds gets a design back we're
using all the best machine learning the
Google cloud has to offer and running it
on GPUs I'll get it a little bit more
into how we're doing it but we're very
excited about this we think this will
change how people go solar so here's how
we're doing it we're taking some powers
years of design expertise the hundreds
of thousands of solar designs we've
created along with our world-class sales
platform that we use today called the
Eddy and we're mashing it together with
what Google brings to the table which is
GCP which as you heard is a zero carbon
emission platform which is great we got
zero carbon emission making more zero
carbon emission as well as Google Maps
and Sun roof data Google has great
imagery of the world and we use that as
our raw data to make this all happen
let's go a little deeper let's go deeper
under the hood so Sun power has those
hundreds of thousands of designs per
year Google has the raw data we train a
model using an annotate roofs put them
in a cloud storage bucket trained the
model in cloud ml engine and then every
time a homeowner enters an address we
run it through that engine to detect the
roof and look for the obstructions
basically just what you saw before that
we did manually 2,000 times a week we
then once we have the environment
characterized we lay out the solar
panels we do a shade analysis we create
an energy estimate and then out pops a
design that actually is a
computer-generated design
so I'll show you instant design now I
have to say we're a little scared of the
curse of the live demos this is a video
it's actually at real time not sped up
but you can go check it out for yourself
the working software all the way over
there
at the industry pavilion where we'll
have people to demo it all week so here
it is and this is a test environment
this isn't really what the homeowner
would see but we got the technology up
and working and we're pretty excited to
share it home and are interested address
our favorite test house clicks create
design we're doing all the same stuff
you saw before this is a however in
real-time outlining the roof looking for
the obstructions looking for the trees
laying out the panels figuring out the
shade that which then lets us get to the
energy and then you know 60 seconds
later we get a design so it might be a
little bit of a way actually it's faster
than that that's real time that's about
17 seconds for that particular house and
you can see it isn't 3d well maybe I'll
show it one more time Oh
so it actually takes almost as long to
enter the address as it does to run this
and we're very fortunate to be using
platform that lets us go really fast
I've never appreciated GPUs as much as I
do today and how fast they can actually
process all this very intensive data
really quickly to get answers for
homeowners fast so you see the 3d model
there we have all the obstructions and
then we have the energy data as well as
much more up behind that so let me show
you these are all designs made with
instant design these are all
computer-generated no human involved
whatsoever and you'll notice that
they're not perfect you know a couple
panels might be a skew or we might be
missing a spot where we could place
another couple and that's okay as we do
this more and as we train the model more
it will only get stronger you'll also
notice if you're an expert and solar
that we have panels on the north side of
the roof we have some panels facing
northeast we've got a lot of panels
everywhere and that's also intentional
because we want to give homeowners the
choice to choose the aesthetic and also
system size that meets their energy
needs they get to down select from these
what we call maximum fit designs because
some homeowners may want solar on the
back of their house if it were me I'd
want it on the front be really proud
about it on my house some homeowners
only need SunPower solar a little bit of
it because they have a very
energy-efficient house and then some
homeowners need a lot of solar because
they've got an e V TVs pool etc and they
need to run a lot of energy through
their house so let's zoom up this is why
we're doing this if Google wants a cloud
computer in every hand or on every desk
Sun power is interested in solar on
every roof and to me
you know applications like this to
better the human condition and our
health and the health of our environment
are really the best uses of machine
learning so we see some power instant
design as an early example of everything
that we can do to move you know the
planet and the environment forward I
also think it's one of the finer
examples of what we can do with GPUs so
imagine if we took all those GPUs
currently mining for Bitcoin and
redirected them to mined for solar in
the cloud could we design all those
hundred million future solar homes in an
afternoon potentially so we're very
excited to launch this it's arriving
this summer and people in select
California cities can go to our website
and enter in their address and then get
a solar design for their home until then
go to Sun power calm slash design to
learn more and to find out what its
coming to your area and of course for
everyone here in the audience and at the
at the expo you can go actually check it
out yourself at the Sun power booth in
the energy section very excited to
launch this and thank you everyone for
coming to our talk the three of us will
be around after four questions and then
I was told also to move one forward
ahead to say complete the survey so
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]